Benim beçik 9 sınıf örerim coğraf kodar
okuluna YouTube'un en büyük coğrafi
kanalına Hepiniz hoş geldiniz zova
öğretmenleri ile beraber yaptığımız
okula destek kampımızı bugün geldik 19
gününe bugün nüfusun dağılışına
bakacağız çok önemli bir videodur
konudur bu özellikle Hem üniversite
sınavında hem de yazılıda Buradan en az
bir iki soru gelir Burası çok değerlidir
dünyada nüfus nerede yoğun nerede seyrek
Türkiye'de nüfus nerede yoğun nerede
seyrek ve göçleri göreceğiz çok değerli
bir konuya geçiş yapmak için ben
kalemimi aldım hazırım Sen de beğen
tuşuna basıp abone olarak Hazırlandı
isan O zaman ne diyoruz Yunus hocayla
bir defa öğren bir daha asla unutma zedu
ile eğitim her yerde geldik 19 güne zedu
v.com sitesinden ücretsiz bir şekilde
böyle renkli bir şekilde pdf'i
indirebilirsin bakın Bugünkü konumuzun
ismine bakın nüfusun dağılışı yani Dünya
üzerinde nüfus nerede sererek nerede
yoğun bu değerli Türkiye üzerinde nüfus
nerede soğuk nerede seyrek nerede yoğun
buna bakacağız sonra da göçler var dünya
tarihi boyunca yapılmış bazı göçler var
bazı kavramlar var bu kavramları
öğreneceğiz ilk olarak gençler dünyada
nüfus her yerde öyle eşit dağılmıyor
Bazı yerlerde çok seyrek Bazı yerlerde
çok yol Bunun nedenleri var işte bunun
nedenleri ne yine coğrafyada coğrafyayı
da ayırdığımız gibi her şeyi ayırdığımız
gibi coğrafyada doğal ve beşeri olarak
ayırıyoruz yani nüfus bir yerde yoğunsa
seyrekse bunun doğal nedenleri oluyor ne
mesela iklim koşulları böyle kabaca
yorumlayabilirsiniz
ama ben yine de bir yorum göstereyim
anlatayım sana mesela göreceğiz Az sonra
Dünya üzerinde nerede yoğun nerede
seyrek diye göreceğiz orada iyice
oturacak kafana mesela iklim e çöl var E
çok sıcak O zaman burada nüfus seyrek
oluyor bak benim dağılışını etkiledi mi
doğal bir şey mi doğal bir şey e ılıman
iklimler var mesela Akdeniz iklimi
ılıman kuşak iklimi e Akdeniz ikliminde
insanlar çok fazla yoğun yerleşiyor bak
İklim benim dağılışını etkiledi mi
etkiledi bak diğeri yer şekilleri eğimli
yerler dağlık yerler yükselti bak eğimli
yerler yüksek yerler insanlar böyle
yüksek eğimli yerlere yerleşebilir mi
yok mesela Himalaya Dağları dünyada
Himalaya dağları var değil mi o Himalaya
dağlarının olduğu yer Hani dağları
öğrendik ya biz seninle dünya haritası
kampında çölleri öğrendik ya İşte bunun
için öğreniyoruz o Himalaya dağlarının
olduğu yer ne olacak yüksek eğimli
seyrek nüfuslu yer olacak yükselti benim
nüfusum seyrek ya da yoğun olmasını
etkiledi mi Evet Toprak özellikleri
gençler verimli Topraklar var delta
ovaları var mesela Nil nehrinin olduğu
yer Az sonra dünya haritasında
göstereceğim sana O deltaya ne oluyor
verimli olduğu için bizim ülkemizde de
çukur hava var mesela ne oluyor İnsanlar
oraya yerleşiyorlar ama verimsiz
yerlerden insanlar kaçıyorlar değil mi E
su kaynakları çevresi Nil Nehri çevresi
mesela İnsanlar hep Nil nehrinin
çevresine yerleşmiş Mısır'da nedeni ne
su var çünkü kara ve denizlerin dağılışı
Kuzey yarımkürede daha çok çok kara var
bu yüzden insanlar daha çok Kuzey
yarımkürede yaşıyor doğal afetler
tropikal fırtınaların olduğu yerler
çığlar olduğu yerler depremlerin olduğu
yerler daha az seyrekleşiyor Bunlar
doğal faktörler bunların doğrultusunda
nüfusun nasıl dağıldığını Az sonra
göreceğiz kabaca sana nasıl etkilediğini
anlatıyorum beşeri faktörler ekonomi bir
yerde tarım Sanayi ulaşım Madencilik
Turizm varsa insanlar orada para olduğu
için oraya yerleşiyorlar E şu an dünyada
nüfusun en fazla olduğu yer Avrupa
Amerika'nın doğusu Çin Japonya buralarda
Sanayi var Ulaşım var para var Ticaret
var insanlar da buralara yerleşiyorlar
Demek ki ekonomik faaliyetler bizim
yerleşmemiş kaynaklanan bir nüfusun
yoğun olma durumu var tarihi kültürel
bir yerleşim oluyor insanlar orada
tarihten beri hep var oluyor ya da dini
bir yer oluyor dini bir yer olduğu için
orası kalabalık oluyor siyasi
nedenlerden dolayı da insanlar bir yere
yoğun yerleşebilir ya da oradan
kaçabilirler gidebilir e insanlar nüfus
ülkelerin uyguladığı nüfus
politikalarından dolayı da nüfus artış
hızları artıp yoğunlaşıp seyrekleşir
göçler göç veriyor bazı ülkeler e bazı
ülkeler de göç alıyor gelişmemiş ülkeler
göç veriyorlar gelişmiş ülkelere doğru
göç gidiyor bu da nüfusun dağılışında
etkili o zaman değil mi mantıken ve
beşeri afetler Bütün bunlar bakın nüfus
dağılışında etkili Peki bu etkili bu
etkiler doğrultusunda dünyada nüfus
Nasıl dağılıyor Şimdi gelelim asıl
önemli olan kısma dünyada nüfusun
nerelerde seyrek nerelerde yoğun olduğu
kısmına bu harita biraz tam olarak
istediğimiz şeyi göstermiyor Yani o
yoğunluğu tam hissettirmiyor göstermiyor
biraz çok fazla kırmızı nokta olduğu
için gerçekten yoğun asıl yoğun yerleri
göremiyoruz Biz gençler size ne diyorum
ben her seferinde dünya haritası
kampımız var Sen bir 9 sınıf öğrencisin
bu dünya haritası kampını bitirmezsen
yapamayız konularda ilerleyemez bak
Okyanus akıntılarını gördük bu bu zamana
gelene kadar çölleri gördük iklimleri
gördük Hep bunlarla alakalı Şimdi
dünyada nüfusun nerelerde yoğun
nerelerde seyrek olduğunu yine bu harita
üzerinden göstereceğim sana bu haritayı
kullanamıyoruz buradaki bu haritayı
getirip bu haritayı anlattığım videoyu
getirip koyacağım oradan dinleyeceksin
Şimdi ve geleceksin Dersimize devam
edeceğiz dikkatli dinle dünyada nüfusun
yoğun olduğu yerler bizim için çok
değerli gelsin video Bakın şimdi geldik
Amerika Amerika Kuzey Amerika'ya bakalım
Kuzey Amerika'da nüfus nerede dağılmış
bakın daha çok apalaş dağlarının
bulunduğu bu bölgede dağılmış Çünkü
apalaş dağları taş kömürü yataklarının
olduğu yer taş kömüründen dolayı burada
Sanayi var aynı zamanda Burası Avrupa'ya
da yakın bakın Sanayi ulaşım var burada
teknoloji var burada Aslında her şey var
burada aynı zamanda bir şey daha
söyleyeyim size ılıman okyanusal iklim
değil mi burası İnsanların şöyle ılıman
okyonusal iklim yani insanların
yaşayabileceği bir iklim var burada o
zaman bütün hepsini to topladığınızda
nüfus nerede burada doğuda yerleşmiş
insanlar Anlaştık mı bakın bunu
ezberleme gerek yok direkt çıkıyor
şurada Meksika civara da nüfus fazla
burada doğum oranları da fazla
Meksika'da Tamam nüfus Demek ki
Amerika'da doğuya Meksika'ya doğru
kaymış Güney Amerika'daki durumumuza
bakalım gençler şu gördüğünüz bölgeye
bakmanızı istiyorum Şurayı gözünüzü açın
ve şöyle bir inceleyin bakın Buralar dağ
seyrek nüfuslu Burası çöl seyrek nüfuslu
e insanlar şurada Şili'de nereye
yerleşecekler dağa yerleşememe çöle
yerleşememe gelmiş Sadece şu bölgeye
yerleşebilmek olduğu bölge değil miydi
orası gördünüz mü peki hocam diğer
tarafta nereye yerleşecek bakın şurası
komple Ekvatoral iklim O yüzden İnsanlar
biraz daha böyle kıyı kesimine kaçmışlar
Bak bu tarafa gel Burada da kıyı
kesimine kaçmışlar görüyor musunuz
şuralara bak kıyı kesimlerine kaçmışlar
iklimi biliyorsun Dağı çölü biliyorsun
çıkıyor Afrika'ya bakacağım e çöl E
hocam şurada öğreneceğiz Nil Nehri var
Nil nehrinin çevresine kaçmış şurada
Ekvator civarı var Nijerya buraya kaçmış
doğum oranları fazla burada Buraya
kaçmış Şurada da Atlas dağlarının
kuzeyinde Akdeniz iklimi olduğu için
buraya
kaçabilmek ulaşım burada iklim uygun
hepsi burada Akdeniz ikliminin olduğu
yer şurada şurada yok bakın Burası çöl
şurada Nil Nehri çevresi Yo nüfus şurada
bir kalabalık var Moskova Ruslar da
oraya yerleşmişler daha çok yine
Avrupa'ya doğru kaymış bak geliyor başka
Hindistan çok yoğun nüfuslu bakın
Himalayalar seyrek Çöller seyrek nüfuslu
yoğun değil ve Güneydoğu Asya'da Çin'i
Japonya'nın olduğu bölge Burası niye
yoğun nüfuslu burada Sanayi var burada
ulaşım var burada Ticaret var burada
para var Hindistan'da niye yoğun
nüfuslar doğum oranları fazla olduğu
için unutma Peki hocam Ne oldu ya bir
hata çıktı Ne oldu dedim ya korktum
bir Hindistan'da doğum oranları olduğu
için nüfus burada bak çok fazla ama
Güneydoğu as ya da şurada Sanayi ulaşım
para var bakın şurada Endonezya var
Normalde burada Ekvatoral iklim bu kadar
fazla yoğun olmaması lazım Ama Endonezya
halkı çok fazla çocuk yapan doğum
oranlarının yüksek olduğu bir halk e
nüfus da gideceği fazla bir arazi yok
bir ada ülkesi O yüzden ada ülkesi küçük
bir ülke nüfus da fazla oraya yığılmış
yoğunluk fazla olmuş Avustralya'da da
bir yeri işaretlemem isterse şu köşeye
işaretleyin tamam mı buraya nüfus
yoğunlaşmıştır işaretlemedim
anlatmadığım yer var mı yok gibi geçelim
hemen buradaki haritamıza bakın burada
Kuzey Amerika'nın doğusu Meksika çevresi
Brezilya'nın doğusu Batı Avrupa Nijerya
çevresi Nil Nehri çevresi bunları
anlattım az önce sana 7 Hindistan
çevresi 8 Endonezya Çin Japonya çevresi
Şurayı Biz kendimiz yazacağız seyrek
bölge çöl bölgesi a Yazın buraya dağlık
Bölge B Yazın buraya Kutup Bölgesi bakın
burada C Yazın buraya Şuraya bak
ormanlık bölge görüyor musun D Yazın
buraya D ormanlık bölge bölge Şimdi
gelelim buraya nüfusun yoğun olduğu
alanları işaretleyelim bir kere şurada
Amerika'nın olduğu bölge Meksika'nın
olduğu bölge şurada güneyde şu kısım
Güney Amerika'da şu kısımlarda şurada
şurada Şili'nin bulunduğu bölgede geldik
bu tarafa Avrupa'yı komple
işaretleyebilir şöyle atlas'ın olduğu
bölgeyi Nijerya'nın bulunduğu bölgeyi
işaretleyebilir şurada Moskova'nın
olduğu kısmı işaretleyebilir şurada
Hindistan'ı işaretledikten
da işaret atabiliriz işaret demediğin
var mı Aa bak Nil nehrinin çevresini
unutuyordum Nil nehrinin çevresini
işaret Tamam şöyle yoğun nüfus alanları
Sen kendin bakın etkinlikleri ilk önce
kendiniz yapın sonra ben doldururken
benden bakın Tamam geçelim diğer kısma
Hah geldik şimdi buraya bak şimdi bu düz
beyaz haritayı Niye ben kabartılı da
koyabilirim renkli de koyabilirim
koymadım düz beyaz harita koydum niye
biliyor musunuz Gençler her şeyi
tasarlayarak yapıyorum bazen kabartılı
koruyorum sonra bazen de düz koyuyorum
Çünkü senin şu an artık düz beyaz
haritada şu yeri sana gösterdiğinde
burayı ormanlık yer diye gözünün o yeşil
gelmesi lazım hocam Burası ormanlık yer
seyrek orman diyeceksin Tamam 3
numaranın olduğu yere bak a hocam Burası
Ant dağlarının olduğu yerde seyrek
dağlardan dolayı diyeceksin yükseltiden
dolayı diyeceksin 4E bakalım hocam
Burası ekvatoru saran iklimde Tamam
seyrek seyrek iklimden dolayı diyeceksin
5 hocam Burası Nijer yaın bulunduğu
bölgeydi yoğun neden doğumların fazla
olmasından 6 neresi Avrupa hemen Ne
diyeceksin yoğun Avrupa nasıl yoğun
neden Sanayi Ticaret Finans ulaşım
hepsini yazabilirsin 7 bakın kızılkum
Karakum çölleri seyrek çöl yazabilirsin
iklim yazabilirsin Yazım da çok güzel
değil mi 8 bakın sert karasal iklim
seyrek neden sert karasal iklim iklimden
soğuk diyebiliriz buna çöl sıcak
diyebilirsin hepsi aynı şey gençler 9
şurası yoğun nüfuslu Bangladeş yoğun
neden doğumlar fazla doğumlar fazla
olduğu için 10 Çin bölgesi yoğun Sanayi
yazabilirsin Sanayi ulaşım Ticaret
Bunları yazabilirsin 11 11 nerede
Endonezya çevresi yoğun neden yoğun
doğumlar fazla ve doğumlardan dışında
bir de arazi dar arazi dar olunca aynı
yere fazla insan giriyor yoğunluk
artıyor 12 çöl Burası seyrek neden
çölden dolu tamam şimdi şuraya bak
dünyada nerede yoğun olduğunu nüfusun
nerede seyrek olduğunu öğrendin Çöllerin
seyrek olduğunu Amazon K havzasının
seyrek olduğunu şimdi neden hocam bunun
üstünde göstermediniz bize Çünkü gençler
bir bilgiyi öğrenirken gerçek kabartmalı
görebileceğin bir harita üzerinde
öğrenmen lazım şimdi o haritada biz onu
kabartmalı öğrendik Bu haritada
öğretmeye kalksam sana ya şurasının çöl
olduğunu anlamıyorsun bakın şurasının
niye yoğun olduğunu ya da şurasının
gerek olduğunu anlayamıyorsun o haritada
ama burasının Amazon Ormanları olduğunu
anlıyorsun ve o haritada öğrendiğin için
şimdi sen şu Güney Amerika'ya baktığında
Aa hocam şurada Ben biliyorum burada
ormanlık alan var gözünün önüne geliyor
şurası çöl O sarı sarı gözünün önüne
geliyor böyle gerçekçi haritalarda
çalışmak lazım gerçekçi haritalarda
çalışırsak bu düz beyaz haritaları
dilsiz haritaları rahatlıkla yorumların
Şimdi ne yaptın sen dünyada yoğun
nüfuslu yerleri seyrek nüfuslu yerleri
öğrendin şimdi gel seninle o zaman şu
buradaki etkinliği yapalım orada da
etkinlik yaptık burada da yapalım Doğu
Asya'da Japonya ve Güney Kore ha hocam
burada Sanayi vardı Sanayi faaliyetleri
vardı insanlar fazla kalabalıktı Burası
yoğun nüfuslu yerdi değil mi Neden
dolayı yoğundu Sanayi diyebiliriz ulaşım
ticaret para diyebiliriz Kuzey Afrika'da
Sahra Çölü hocam seyrek nüfus neden su
yok Sıcaklık fazla su yok tamam
Avustralya kıtasının ortası hocam burası
çöldü o zaman seyrek nüfuslu neden
çölden dolayı ABD'nin Doğu kıyıları
hocam Sanayi vardı burada yoğun nüfus şu
an gözünün önüne getiriyorsun Dünya
haritasını Tamam işte dünya haritasında
öyle çalıştığın zaman şimdi
yapabiliyorsun gözünün önüne getir
Kanada'nın Kuzey kesimleri hocam
Kanada'nın Kuzey kesimleri Burası soğuk
Kutup Bölgesi o zaman seyrek nüfuslu
Güney Amazon havzası Güney Amerika'da
Amazon havzası hocam ormanlık bölge
seyrek nüfuslu Sibirya ve Grönland soğuk
seyrek nüfuslu düşük sıcaklıklar
güneydoğu Asya h Hindistan Çin yoğun
nüfuslu doğum oranlarının fazla olması
Hindistan'da Çin'de sanayinin olması
Batı Avrupa sanayinin fazla olmasından
dolayı yoğun nüfuslu Arabistan
Yarımadası seyrek nüfuslu çöl bölgesi
bunları böyle işaretle bildiysem Senin
işin Tamam gelelim Dünya nüfusunun
kıtalara dağılımına gençler dünyada en
fazla nüfus Asya kıtasındadır e Çin
Hindistan burada milyarlarca nüfus var
İkisinde Ee o zaman Asya kıtasında en
fazla nüfus Sadece bu iki ülke bir ile
tek başına zaten yetiyor Demek ki en
fazla nüfus Asya kıtasında Bunun nedeni
ne e doğum oranları çok yüksek orada
Hindistan'da diğer ülkelerde de doğum
oranları yüksek Bu yüzden gençler bakın
Avrupa kıtasında nüfus artış hızı azdır
çocuk yapmazlar öyle çok hızlı artmaz
orada nüfus Ama buna rağmen dışarıdan
göç alır çünkü Avrupa'da para var Sanayi
var çalışacak iş iş var Afrika'dan ve
Asya'dan birçok insan buraya göçle gider
doğum oranları düşüktür Ama burası göç
alır bu bilgiyi Unutma bak komum
oranlarının yüksek olması nedeniyle
Dünya nüfus artış hızının Bak şuraya
dikkat et artış hızının en yüksek olduğu
yer Afrika bak Asya ne dünyada nüfus
miktarının Lütfen bunu yaz nüfus nüfus
miktarı bunu not al nüfus miktarının en
fazla olduğu yer Asya Çin Hindistan çok
kalabalık Afrika ne hocam Afrika nüfus
artış hızının hızının en fazla olduğu
yer doğum oranları Burada çok fazla
Gençler bu yüzden en fazla dünyada nüfus
artış hızı Afrika'da en az nüfusa sahip
kıtada Avustralya E zaten orada küçücük
dünyanın bir diğer ucunda bir kıta çoğu
yeri de çöl en az nüfus orada gençler
ABD ve Kanada'ya insanlar göç ediyorlar
bizim ülkemizden de şu an ekonomik
koşullar kötü olduğu için insanlar daha
çok Amerika ve Kanada'ya gitmeye
çalışıyorlar Bu yüzden Kuzey Amerika
aldığı göçlerden dolayı kalabalıklaşıyor
Güney Amerika'da Peki nüfus neden
artıyor Bunun nedeni doğum oranlarının
fazla olması Sanayi mi var orada yok
insanlar niye orada artıyor şu an doğum
oranlarının fazla olması Şimdi gelelim
Türkiye'de nüfusun dağılışına çok çok
değerli bilgiler Bakın bu dünya ve
Türkiye'de nüfusun böyle dağılışı bizim
için çok değerli ama yine bakın nasıl
bir harita koymuş Burada şimdi burada
nüfus neden seyrek ya da yoğun bunu
bilemiyorsun gerçek kabartmalı harita
lazım O yüzden şimdi kabartmalı haritayı
açacağım onun üzerinden anlatacağım sana
Evet şöyle bakın bu kabartmalı harita
üzerinden öğrenirseniz rahat
öğrenirsiniz Şimdi size ilk olarak
seyrek nüfuslu yerleri göstereyim
gençler Şuraya bir bakar mısınız şu
Sinop ve çevresi bakın şurası şu Sinop
ve çevresi seyrek fusu neden seyrek
nüfuslu biraz daha ince inceltebilir
muyuz bunu Ha şöyle bakın Sinop ve
çevresi Burası gençler şöyle Türkiye'ye
bir bakın Normalde şöyle Kuzey Anadolu
dağları uzanıyor ya şöyle Biz
İstanbul'dan yola çıktığımızda
Samsun'dan içeri şöyle geçeriz
Samsun'dan geçtikten sonra Karadeniz
kıyı kuşağından ilerleriz yani ulaşım
buradan gider bu Sinop çevresi Bakın şu
bölge ulaşımın tersinde kalıyor Burası
ulaşımın tersinde kaldığı için e burada
ekonomi de yok o zaman insanlar buradan
göç etmek zorunda kalıyor buradaki
mantığı Anladık mı Sinop çevresindeki
Hakkari şurada şu tarafta Hakkari ve
çevresi bakın dağlık engebeli ulaşımdan
uzak e çalışacak ekonomik olarak bir şey
yok o yüzden burası seyrek şurası
Erzurum Kars ardağan çevresi şu bölge
bakın dağlık engebeli yüksek buraya
baktığınızda dağları göreceksiniz
dağları g göreceksiniz bakın zaten uç
noktalar Türkiye'nin uç noktaları ulaşım
güzergahlarından uzak Burası seyrek
nüfuslu yerler dağlık engebeli Sanayi
yok ulaşım Yok bunları Zaten çıkartırsın
rahat bu tarafa doğru yaklaşıyorum
gençler şurası Yıldız dağlarının olduğu
yer burası da çok uzak hat buradan
geçiyor ulaşım hattı Burası dağlık yer
burası dağlık olduğu için ve tam böyle
Kıyıda köşede kaldığı için seyrek şurası
Çanakkale şu gördüğünüz bölge İstanbul
bütün ulaşımı kendi üzerine almış
İzmir'den gelen hat larda ulaşım hatları
da böyle geçiyor Ve şu Çanakkale çevresi
de bakın ulaşımdan uzak olduğu için
seyrek nüfuslu alanlardan bir tanesi ben
burayı gezdim en son seyrek nüfuslu
Şimdi de Kars Ard Dağı'na gideceğiz yine
seyrek nüfuslu olacak gezerken rahat
oluyor güzel oluyor ama seyrek nüfus
olması çok hoş olmuyor Burası seyrek
nüfus mesela da dağlık yerler de var
güneyine doğru Kaz Dağları var ama
ulaşım hatlarından uzak olduğu için
seyrek nüfuslanan ama buraya 1915
Çanakkale Köprüsü yapıldı Şimdi Belki
düzelir başka Şimdi gelelim güneye
güneydeki kısım çok önemli bizim için
bakın gençler Pardon arada böyle atlama
yapıyor şöyle şurası Menteşe Yöresi
burayı unutmayın Muğla Menteşe Yöresi
Burası seyrek nüfusludur Siz şimdi
Antalya'nın bu Bulunduğunuz bu bölgenin
şey sanıyorsunuz böyle yoğun nüfusludur
Antalya o Herkes orada falan Hayır Bakın
şu Menteşe Yöresi seyrek nüfuslu dağlık
engebeli karstik arazi var burada bakın
yine bu Antalya'nın şurada teke Taşeli
platoları dediğimiz yer Buralar seyrek
nüfus şuraya bakın ya niye atıyor
kendini bak şu çıkıntıyı görüyor musun
Şu çıkıntıyı Gençler bu iki çıkıntının
olduğu bu yer dağlık engebeli yerlerdir
bunu bileceksin böyle Gerçek bir
haritada çalışırsan anlarsın oranın niye
seyrek olduğunu Burası karstik arazi her
taraf böyle eriyor dağlık engebeli
berbat bir arazi Burası teke teke teke
taş eli Taşeli platoları diyoruz biz
bunlara Buralar seyrek burada nüfus
nereye yığılmış şuralara neyse onu Az
sonra gösteririm şimdi ilk önce seyrek
yerleri göstereyim bakın Dünya
Türkiye'de nüfusun seyrek olduğu yerler
ne dedik Sinop çevresi Erzurum Kars
Ardahan çevresi Hakkari çevresi teke
Taşeli platoları Menteşe Yöresi
Çanakkale çevresi Yıldız Dağları çevresi
ve bir tane daha var şurada Ya arkadaş
Dur şu tuz gölünün şu güneyi var ya şu
iç kısım gençler şu iç kısım Burası
nedeni de kuraklık su yok orada Çok
kurak bir yer orası seyrek nüfuslu
yerler Türkiye'deki seyrek nüfuslu
alanlar Buralar Şimdi gelelim yoğun
nüfuslu alanlara birincisi şu Şu
İstanbul'un olduğu yer ve çevresi bakın
Bursa'yı şöyle işte Sakarya'yı
kocaeli'yi içine alan yer burası yoğun
nüfus neden Sanayi var Ulaşım var para
var Her şey burada Ticaret burada Bakın
bu İstanbul ve çevresi yoğun nüfus Hatta
bunu şöyle biraz Tekirdağ'a doğru da
kaydırabilir Evet başka şöyle İzmir
Manisa ve Aydın çevresi Burası da yine
bakın şöyle Burada da Sanayi var tarım
var Ulaşım var insanlar nereye yerleşmiş
bakın Türkiye'de ulaşımın daha çok
olduğu yerlere şöyle İzmir ve çevresi
İstanbul ve çevresi Peki hocam Şu
Antalya kısmına bak şurası teke taş
eliydi Peki Antalya'da insanlar nerede
yaşıyorlar Hay senim be Antalya'da
insanlar şurada bakın şurada traverten
ovası var Antalya'da burada yaşıyorlar
Antalya'da İnsanlar burada yaşıyorlar bu
tarafta Hocam şöyle bakın Taşeli seyrek
ama şurada Adana şurada Hatay'ı içine
alan kısım ve buradan Şanlıurfa'ya
Gaziantep Doğru giden kısım burada nüfus
yoğun burada tarım yapılıyor burada
ulaşım ulaşım da var bakın burada
Çukurova var Buralar da tarım arazileri
Burası ulaşım limanlar var burada tarım
var burada para yine Güneydoğu'nun
parası da bu kısımda toplanmış Marmara
burada toplanmış Ege burada toplanmış
bakın Akdeniz Antalya şu kıyı kösem'de
şu taraf Güneydoğu Anadolu burada
toplanmış Peki Karadeniz nerede
toplanıyor Karadeniz'de gençler şu kıyı
kesim inde toplanıyor şöyle Samsun'a
doğru uzanan kıyı kesiminde toplanıyor
Çünkü arka taraf dağlık engebeli
buralarda Karadeniz'deki nüfusun
toplandığı yerler şimdi şu haritayı
şöyle gözünü açıp şöyle bakmanı
istiyorum dikkat et dağların uzanışı yla
düz yerlerle her şeyle paralel sen böyle
kabartmalı bir harita üzerinde
çalıştığında
yorumlamanın Gel bakalım şimdi geldim
şuraya şimdi bunun üzerinden öğrensek
anlayamayacaksın Çünkü dağlık yeri
görmüyor ama şimdi görüyorsun O
kabartmalı haritada gördün ha hocam
şuralar dağlıktır şuralarda Samsun'a
geçiyorduk O yüzden şurası artık
ulaşımın dışında kalıyor hak Hakkari
Erzurum çevresi dağlık Aa Hocam ben
şurada teket Taşeli görüyorum o dağlık
denizin kenarındaki uçurumları görüyorum
o yüzden Buralar seyrek hocam şurada
Menteşe Yöresi seyrek buradaki dağlık
yeri görüyorum Çanakkale kısmı seyrek
ulaşımdan uzak Yıldız dağlarının olduğu
kısım seyrek Bak şimdi dağlık ler
oralarda geldim yoğun yerlere ha Hocam
şu kıyı kesiminde yoğunlaşıyor bak
Ankara'yı Demeyi Unuttum size iç kısımda
Ankara çevresine baş kentimiz olduğu
için yoğun nüfus İzmir ve çevresi yoğun
Antalya şu kıyı kesiminde yerleşmiş
bakın Adana çevresi şöyle komple almış
burayı Şanlıurfa'ya doğru ve şöyle
İstanbul ve çevresi Bu kadar basit
Aslında bu Türkiye haritasında bunu
görmek bunlarla alakalı soru çözdüğümüz
de çuk diye oturacak kafanıza Ah be şu
ÖSYM sorusu olmasaydı bunu çözer
diiktiraf bırakıyorum örnek 4 cevap şu
diye yorumlara yazın Tamam buraya kadar
Tamam mıyız bu videodan sonra test
sorusu çözeceğiz Bu konuyla alakalı çok
test sorusu çözeceğiz hem de o test soru
çözümünü kesinlikle kaçırmıyor orada bu
konuyu didik didik edeceğiz kafana iyice
oturacak Şimdi gelelim göçlere bak
insanların bulundukları yerden doğal
ekonomik sosyal siyasal ve kültürel
nedenlerle başka bir yere hareket
etmesine göç denir ya bu tanımı böyle
bilmene gerek yok göç ne olduğunu
biliyoruz Biz çeşitli nedenlerden
kalkacağız başka bir yere gideceğiz
geçmişten beri hep bu göç olayları
yaşandı Ama bu yaşanırken gençler bir
itici nedenler olur Bir de çekici
nedenler olur itici neden dediğimiz şey
şudur Sen köyde yaşıyorsun köyün
sevmediğin şeyleri vardır eğitime
ulaşamıyorsunuz ekonomik olarak para
kazanamıyorsan Bak bunlar hep itici
nedenler seni köyden iten nedenler böyle
düşüneceksin Bir de çekici nedenler var
bu ne bu göç Göçe gittiğin yer mesela
İstanbul'a gideceksin değil mi
İstanbul'un seni çeken nedenleri var
nedir Bunlar para var orada çalışacak
şey var imkan var Sağlık Eğitim
imkanları var Bunlar da İstanbul için
çekici neden çekici nedenler göçün
yapıldığı yer itici nedenler göçün
çıktığı yeri ifade ediyor Tamam şimdi
gençler gelelim göçün nedenlerine bak
doğal nedenler ekonomik nedenler siyasi
nedenler diye şöyle yorumlayalım bunu
ezberleme gerek yok Bak doğal nedenler
Demek ki doğayla alakalı olacak ne bu
Çığ sel heyelan geçmişte Bunlar olmuş
heyelan olmuş deprem olmuş insanlar bu
doğal nedenler Bunlar doğal bir şey
doğal nedenlerden dolayı göç etmişler
başka bir yere Ben şimdi Çığdan dolayı
heyelandan dolayı göç edersem bu ne olur
doğal bir neden olur değil mi Bunu
getirip bunun altına koyacaksın kuraklık
yaşanıyor e insanlar tarımsal üretim
yapamıyor göç ediyor doğal bir şey
volkanizma deprem Tsunami bakın iklim
koşullarının kötü olması tarım yapamaz
hale gelmek toprağın artık işlenemiyor
olm ası Bunların hepsi doğal Neden şimdi
bir de ekonomik nedenlere bakalım köydes
İş bulamıyorsun parasal bir şey ekonomik
bir şey ne olur gitmek zorunda kalırsın
değil mi iş imkanlarından dolayı geçim
sıkıntısı yaşadığın için tarım
alanlarının bölünmesi bu ne alaka tarım
alanlarının miras yoluyla bölünmesi Bu
bir ekonomik nedendir Nasıl yani Şöyle
Senin baban yaşıyordur Mesela bir sürü
10 dönüm arazisi vardır Bu 10 dönüm
arazisinde yapılan tarım bakıyordu
aileye ama Baban Öldü Allah göstermesin
yani baba öldü 10 çocuk var hepsi 10
kişiye bölündü Topraklar herkese birer
dönüm düştü ama o Bir dönüm yetmiyor O
bir kişiyi bakmak için yetmiyor
Topraklar miras yoluyla bölündüğü için
Artık insanlar tarımdan
geçinemeyen Neden mi Evet gelir
dağılımındaki dengesizlikler Yani senin
yaşadığın ilde gelir dağılımından o ile
çok fazla bir pay düşmemiş mecburen
İstanbul'a gitmek zorunda kalıyorsun
gibi ve doğal zenginlikler mesela
Batman'da güzel bir petrol kuyuları var
Batman'da iş imkanı var doğal zenginlik
var o zaman oraya göç ediyorsun ekonomik
bir şey bu peki siyasi nedenler nasıl
bir şey Bak bu sefer siyasi olacak
savaşlar Bir siyasi neden mübadeleyi az
sonra göreceğiz bu kavramı bilmiyorsun
Az sonra göreceksin mesela siyasi
baskılar iş karışıklıklar Suriye'de
mesela yaşanıyor değil mi ülkemize
geliyorlar sınır değişiklikleri iç
karışıklık mülteci durumu bunların hepsi
siyasi bir neden sosyal nedenler sosyal
hayatla alakalı olacak mesela eğitim bir
sağlık imkanı imkanı imkanı imkanı
imkanı unuttum ya demeyi sağlık
imkanları güvenlik sorunu Bunların hepsi
sosyal hayatla alakalı o zaman sosyalin
altına koyacaksın dini kültürel etkenler
daha iyi yaşamak istiyor insan sosyal
bir şey bakın Bütün bunlar da sosyal
nedenler Şimdi gelelim tarih tarihi
göçlere gençler şöyle bakın Türkistan
dediğimiz Orta Asya'dan dünyaya yapılmış
göçler var değil mi Kavimler Göçü
diyoruz biz bunlara bakın milattan önce
1500ler le milattan sonra 800 yüzlere
kadar devam etmiş bayağı bir devam etmiş
Aslında bakın birçok yere gitmişiz
sibirya'ya Rusya'ya balkanlara
Hindistan'a güneye doğru bayağı bayağı
ve uzun yıllar boyunca Bir göç etmişiz
biz buna ne diyoruz Türkistan'dan
yapılan göçler Kavimler Göçü Peki
sorulacak olan soru bu Türkistan'dan
Yapılan bu kavimler göçünün nedenleri
neler Neden insanlar Türkler oradan
yayılmış Orta Asya'dan gençler iklim
değişikliğinden dolayı yaşanan bir
kuraklık var otlaklar azalıyor e Oradaki
insanlar konar göç hayvanlarına
bakmaları lazım E kuraklık olursa orada
Bozkırlı alanlar yeteri kadar yetişemez
otlaklar kurursa insanlar göç etmek
zorunda kalıyorlar bu etkenlerden bir
tanesi yani iklim etkenlerden bir tanesi
iklim oradaki doğal kaynakların nüfusu
yeteri kadar besleyememesi Çünkü nüfus
sürekli artmaya başlamış artmış artmış
ve nüfus arttıkça doğal kaynaklar
azalıyor besleyememesi e o bölgede
Çinliler var Onların yaptığı baskılar
savaşlar bunlara artık dayanamama durumu
Göçe neden olmuş yeni yerler fethetme
arzusu ya Gidelim de yeni yerler bulalım
bu e aynı zamanda Türk boyları Sürekli
kendi aralarında da mücadele ediyorlar
Sürekli yeni devlet kuruyorlar e Bunlar
da oradan gitmelerine neden olmuş Bütün
bunlar sonucunda Kavimler Göçü yaşanmış
bize sorulacak soru ne biliyor musunuz
şurası bu sorulacak Türkler
Türkistan'dan yapılan Türk göçlerinin
nedenlerini yazınız Alın size sınav
sorusu bir diğer sınav sorusu da
mübadele kavramını açıklayarak örnek
veriniz Bunların hepsi bir sınav sorusu
mübadele mücadele böyle düşüneceksin
kodlaması bu mübadele dediğimiz şey şu
gençler böyle savaşlar sonrasında
ülkelerarası çekişmeler sonrasında
insanların toplu olarak yer değiştirmesi
bakın zorunlu zorunlu ve toplu olarak
yer değiştirmesi ne örnek verelim
kafanızda otursun mesela Türkiye
Cumhuriyeti kurulduğunda Osmanlı
toprakları Yunanistan'da da Osmanlı
toprakları vardı değil mi Orada da
yaşayan Türkler vardı şimdi Türkiye'de
yaşayan Rumlar var Türkiye'de yaşayan
Türkler var Yunanistan'da yaşayan Rumlar
var Yunanistan'da yaşayan Türkler var
ama Türkiye Cumhuriyeti Osmanlı dağılıp
da Türkiye Cumhuriyeti kurulduğunda
Yunanistan'da Türkler kalmış Türkiye'de
de Rumlar kalmış ne yapmış devletler
anlaşmışlar demişler ki Sendeki bazı
Türkler bana gelsin Bendeki bazı Rumlar
da sana gelsin Tabii bu değiş tokuş
arasında bazı istisna tutulanlar olmuş
Ama genel olarak gitmişler Yunanistan'a
Türkiye'deki Rumlar Yunanistan'a gitmiş
Yunanistan'daki bazı Türkler de
Türkiye'ye gelmiş Batı Trakya'daki
kalmış ama mesela ne olmuş devletler
buna karar ver vermiş devletler buna
karar vermiş ve öyle Ben gitmiyorum gibi
bir şey yok gideceksin Karadeniz'deki
Rumların hepsi gitmiş mecburi gitmezsen
ölüyorsun direkt sıkıntı Demek ki
zorunlu ve aynı zamanda toplu bütün
Karadeniz'deki toplu halde gitmiş göç et
mübadele dediğimiz şey bu işte mücadele
devletlerin kendi aralarındaki
yaptıkları anlaşmayla zorunlu ve toplu
bir şekilde Göçe zorlamaları Biz bunu
kimle yapmışız yunanistan'la Türkiye
arasında soru şu mübadeleyi açıklayarak
bunu bir örnek veriniz sınav sorusu 10
puan aynı göç Romanya ile Bulgaristan
arasında da gerçekleşmiş mesela Evet
mübadele göçü dediğimiz göç bu sığınmacı
gö göçü mülteciler gençler sığınmacılar
dünyanın birçok yerinde var şu an mesela
Suriye'den birçok insan gelip ülkemize
sığınmacı olarak geliyorlar savaşlardan
dolayı iç karışıklıklardan siyasi ve
etnik baskılardan dolayı başka ülkelere
gidiyor İnsanlar Mesela bizim ülkemizden
de Avrupa'ya giden bir sürü insan var
Türk olup da gidip sığınmacı olarak
mülteci olarak gidenler var Evet şöyle
Amerika'ya bir sürü mülteci gidiyor
mülteci kavramını artık biliyorsunuz
yakından tanıyorsunuz ülkesinde yaşanan
savaşlar iç karışıklar siyasi etnik
baskılardan dolayı insanların başka
ülkelere gitmeleri ve bu gidişler
sıkıntılı gidişler böyle bakın
mülteciler genelde gençler Türkiye'yi
bir Güzergah olarak kullanmaya
çalışıyorlar ve özellikle gitmek
istedikleri yer Avrupa Çünkü Avrupa'da
zenginlikler var daha çok para
kazanıyorlar Türkiye'yi bir geçiş yeri
olarak düşünüyorlar Tabii ki dönem dönem
Türkiye'den geçebiliyorlar ya da
geçemiyorlar ülkemizde konaklıyor
ülkemizde çok uzun yıllarda
kalabiliyorlar ama ana amaç daha çok
Avrupa'ya kendilerini atabilmek Tabii ki
Avrupa ile yaptığımız anlaşmalardan
dolayı bazen buna izin veriyoruz bazen
vermiyoruz işçi göçleri diye bir kavram
var geçmişte bunu nüfus konusunu
anlatırken 1960'lı yıllardan sonra biz
ne yapmıştık Avrupa'ya Türkler çalışmaya
gitmişti bakın 5861 yıllarında
Almanya'ya gitmişiz işte böyle dünyada
işçi göçleri de oluyor Sadece Almanya'ya
değil Hollanda'ya Fransa'ya Belçika'ya
Türkiye'den giden bir sürü insanlar var
beyin göçü denilen Kavram ne Aslında
bakın Türkçe olduğu için bunlar artık
kodlamak zorunda kalmıyoruz mübadele
mesela Türkçe olmadığı için kodladım
mücadele dedik ama birçok şey artık
Türkçe değil Burada şey Türkçe burada
beyin göçü beyin beynin göç etmesi Bey
derken koca anlamında değil beyin göç
etmesi değil beynin göç etmesi yani şu
gençler kendini geliştirmiş insanlar
oluyor ülkede ya Her anlamda beceri
kazanmış kendini geliştirmiş yetenekli
insanlar oluyor ve bu bu insanlar kendi
ülkelerinde değer görmüyor Türkiye'de
mesela son yıllarda tıpçıların Hepsi
gidiyor değil mi Çünkü değer görmüyor
cumhurbaşkanı bile çıkıp tıpçılara
doktorlara giderseniz gidin diyor şimdi
böyle olunca e Adam da diyor ki Ya bunca
yıl okuduk 6 yıl 7 yıl okuduk hala her
yıl okumaya devam ediyoruz ya buraya
girmek de çok zor dünyanın gelişimini
sağladık geldik burada bize değer
verilmiyor parasal olarak da Her anlamda
hastanelerde dövülüyor öldürülüyoruz ya
Bir sürü sıkıntı Mühendisler Yine öyle
yazılımcılar yine öyle bize değer
verilmiyor deniliyor e değer
verilmiyorsa biz bu ülkeden gideriz
diyorlar ve kendini yetiştirmiş bu
insanların ülkeden gitmesine beyin göçü
deniyor beyin göçü gençler gelişmemiş
ülkeler beyin göçü verir gelişmiş
ülkeler beyin göçü alı bakın Mesela şey
2015'te Nobel kimya ödülünü alan Aziz
Sancar bizim ülkemizde değil gitmiş
beyin göçüyle Gidenlerden bir tanesi
mesela beyin göçü çok sıkıntılı bir iş
asıl Devletleri yok eden şey gençler
beyin göç Çünkü sen onlarca Yıl Eğitim
verdiğin yetiştirdiğin hazineni
kaybediyorsun başka ülkeye gidiyor ve
katkısını O başka ülkeye veriyor parayı
o başka ülkeye kazandırıyor dünyadaki en
tehlikeli şey beyin güç insanları da
suçlayamazsınız Çünkü değer vermezsen
insanlar gider Sen yeterli imkanları
sunmazsa insanlar gider bir de yeni
dünyaya göçler diye bir kavramım var
yeni dünya Eski dünya mı var hocam Evet
Eski dünyadan kastımız Asya Avrupa
kıtalarının Afrika kıtalarının olduğu
kısım yeni dünyadan kastımız da Amerika
dediğimiz yer coğrafi keşiflerle beraber
gençler gittik yeni dünyayı keşfettik
Avrupa'dan insanlar Amerika'ya göç
etmeye başladılar hem Kuzey Amerika'ya
hem Güney Amerika'ya Avrupa'dan insanlar
gidip Afrika'daki insanları gemilere
doldurup Amerika'ya götürdüler
çiftliklerde çalışsınlar diye işte yeni
dünyaya göçler dediğimiz şey bu coğrafi
keşiflerle beraber yapılan göçler şöyle
bakın Evet yine bir ÖSYM sorusu ek 5
cevap şu diye yorumlara bırakıyorsunuz
diyoruz ve nüfusun dünya ve Türkiye
üzerindeki dağılışını da bitiriyoruz
gençler seviliyorsunuz bakın ısrarla
dünya haritaları kampı diyorum size ben
dünya haritaları kampını öğrenmezsen bu
9 sınıfta işimiz yaş oturun dünya
haritaları kampını çalışın 45 günde
bitirirsiniz sonra çok rahat edeceksiniz
seviliyorsunuz Gençler bu dersin soru
çözümünde görüşmek üzere ne diyoruz o
zaman Yunus hocayla bir defa Öğren Bir
de asla unutma zeda ile eğitim her yerde